en septembre 1986 et crée le
conservatoire botanique national de
mascarin sous l'impulsion de botanistes
et d'hommes politiques conscients de la
richesse et de la fragilité du
patrimoine végétal réunionnais trente
ans plus tard le conservatoire botanique
labellisé centre permanent d'initiatives
pour l'environnement travaille sur trois
territoires français de l'océan indien
la réunion mayotte et les îles éparses
fédérer en est d'une importance
particulière puisque le président de la
chaîne mais j'étais absolument
incomparable richesse monétaire mais
aussi et ces chiffres nous alerte
on a aussi une responsabilité puisque
nombre de décès restaient sont en danger
d'extinction donc une démission du
conservatoire c'est vraiment de 2 degrés
pour la connaissance sauvegarder les
espèces en voie de disparition une
responsabilité qui incombe à ce
conservatoire
rien qu'à la réunion 275 espèces
végétales sont menacées
le conservatoire botanique de mascarin
contribuer plus que jamais à la
préservation de la biodiversité dans la
zone 30 ans le conservatoire a obtenu
l'agrément national pour devenir le seul
conservatoire national de tous les
outre-mer il doit y en avoir une
quinzaine sur la métropole et donc c'est
un c'est un plus pour la réunion il faut
non seulement en être fier mais faire en
sorte que nous puissions faire rayonner
les travaux scientifiques qui sont
réalisés par des chercheurs des
botanistes réunionnais ils le font pour
la réunion et nous passons nous mêmes
des commandes sur des espaces nos
espaces naturels sensibles nous avons
trois conventions aujourd'hui avec le
conservatoire botanique des mascarins ce
qui permet aussi de pouvoir les aider
financièrement
et puis de voir une vision une
visibilité jusqu'à
le temps d'une soirée le conservatoire
botanique a fêté son 30e anniversaire en
présence des acteurs politiques
des scientifiques et des agents de la
collectivité qui au quotidien font que
cette structure puisse mener à bien ses
missions conservatoire men men quatre
grandes missions en fait d'abord signer
sur une connaissance connaissance de la
flore et des habitats naturels
connaissance de la flore ça paraît
simple mais on a plus de deux mille
espèces entre mayotte et la réunion et
les îles éparses
donc ça fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de connaissances pour pas mal d
expertise le deuxième volet c'est la
conservation et la gelée dit tout à
l'heure on n'a plus de 500 espèces à
l'échelle du bassin océan indien qui
sont en danger d'extinction donc de
conservation troisième mission qu'une
mission d'expertisé donc on est vraiment
là pour appuyer les collectivités et
l'état pour les aider à prendre des
décisions dans les grands projets
d'aménagement et définir les enjeux et
enfin c'est bien beau de faire de la
science de l expertise du conseil le
troll quatrième axe et de partager avec
l'ensemble du public
les jeunes les moins jeunes les
associations va tout le réseau
associatif et voilà depuis juin 2014
l'association s'est réparti en deux
entités le conservatoire botanique
national de mascarin assure les missions
scientifiques et mascarin jardin
botanique de la réunion assure l'accueil
du public et la gestion des collections
sous la tutelle du service de la
direction de l'environnement au
département de la réunion